[Music]
by joining us again live from Austin
Texas Fox News correspondent at large
were all de Rivera now he is with the
chief of the Austin Police Department
Brian Manley please send my my thanks of
my very high regards to him his
department and all the FBI guys in law
enforcement or although police the chief
can hear you Shawn but listen to what
Governor Greg Abbott said the governor
of Texas said in my time 12 years as
Attorney General of Texas in three years
as governor I have not seen a better job
than what we have seen from this police
chief and the Austin Police was
congratulations chief on the job well
done thank you very much for although I
got to say though those are very high
praise from our governor but I was
actually surrounded by a team of
officers men and women that I have spent
my entire career with but the federal
agents that came and joined us from the
ATF and the FBI and the Postal Service
we had a team that was absolutely
committed to bringing this to an end and
to restoring peace to Austin and so this
was a it was a huge team effort cut
right to the headline the stunning
statement that you made during that big
press conference that you have a 25
minute videotape confession I guess
you'd say from Condit from the 23 year
old bomber so we did we uncovered a
recording that he made on his phone and
although it's a video recording it's in
darkness so you really don't see
anything but during the recording during
the conversation he talks about the
actions that he took in Austin he
describes the six bombs that he
constructed and the seventh bomb that he
had on him that he ultimately detonated
when he killed himself in his
interaction with our SWAT team and you
know just kind of talks about a little
bit about his life and you know anytime
there's an incident like this people
want a motive they want a reason they
want to know why and there really is no
reason and we're trying to assign
rationality to an irrational act and you
know it was it was a chilling insight
into this but you know it sounds to me
like it's a woe is me a narcissistic
Punk who kills two innocent people
wounds five others terrorizes this
community and it's all about him give me
a break well I think for us it was the
evidentiary value of what was on the
video whether it was meant to be
self-serving in that way were never
- no but it was very valuable to us from
from the standpoint that he described
six bombs and enough detail to where we
feel confident that he built all six
bombs because although there were
similarities between all six of them
there were also some things that
distinguished them that we never
released and by his own admission it
made it clear that he understood what
those differences were and made us
confident that he built those you know
she won one of the ironic things is he
coordinated this massive effort federal
state and local and he's only the
interim the acting chief when he gonna
get the job well you know I've had the
blessings of being with the Austin
Police Department for 28 years
these are men and women that I consider
my family and I've enjoyed every single
day so you know if the decision is meant
to be then then it'll be a job well done
thank you well Vecchia Thank You chief
thanks to all the law enforcement thank
you for all